pendant très longtemps le harcèlement
scolaire ça a été considérée comme
quelque chose de normal
moi j'ai entendu pendant souvent et on
entend encore parfois de moins en moins
heureusement mais on entend ce sont des
chamailleries entre enfants c'est normal
que les enfants soient durs entre eux et
c'est moi je refuse complètement cette
idée le bon positionnement qu'on doit
avoir dans une société celle écoute de
l'autre la bienveillance la
compréhension des différences c'est
aussi important pour les enfants de
définir à l'interdît que pour la société
parce que l'enjeu du harcèlement
scolaire c'est que l'ensemble de la
société comprennent que c'est un sujet
majeur et que c'est un sujet qui est un
sujet qui dépasse simplement l'enfance
l'école c'est un sujet de ce qu'on veut
comme modèle de société
ce délit de harcèlement scolaire est
juste une sorte de pivot qui fait le
lien entre tout le travail qu'on doit
faire sur la question du harcèlement
scolaire toute la question de la
prévention de l'accompagnement des
victimes de l'accompagnement des auteurs
aussi et puis le rapport à la société et
ce que dit la société et notre société
aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle doit dire
de la même façon qu'à un moment donné
elle a dit que le harcèlement au travail
ça ne devait pas exister
eh ben je pense que le harcèlement
scolaire ne doit pas exister
et si on veut que tout ça soit compris
par la société je pense que l'inscrire
dans le code pénal est une sorte de de
définition d'un interdit qui permet de
faire tout ce qui existe déjà au tour du
harcèlement scolaire et surtout de
l'amplifier
aujourd'hui l'éducation nationale depuis
une dizaine d'années a pris en compte le
phénomène du harcèlement scolaire a mis
en place un certain nombre de choses et
on avance on avance on va dans la bonne
direction
c'est maintenant une question de moyens
je pense qu'il faut sans doute amplifier
le mouvement donner encore plus de
moyens aux personnes qui accompagnent
qui travaille sur ces sujets ça c'est un
premier point mais il y à aussi la
question des parents et c'est évident
qu'il faut que les parents s'impliquent
dans cette idée du harcèlement qu'il le
comprenne et on a un sujet nouveau qui
est un sujet terrifiant jeu j'emploie
volontairement ce mot c'est la question
de nos enfants sur les réseaux sociaux
de nos enfants en lien au virtuel éolien
à tous ces outils qui sont parfois des
outils formidables pour les
apprentissages pour apprendre pour
rechercher internet c'est génial pour
les enfants pour ça mais c'est aussi un
outil terriblement dangereux et qu'il
faut réguler et qu'il faut accompagner